foreign
hey everybody what's going on see the
camera looks pretty good right yeah yeah
is that is it acceptable
you didn't not quite you didn't come in
soon enough I told you I'll look and see
if that mirror is dead center in there
yeah that's not centered well it's close
enough as long as we're both in it
from a woman's point of view oh yeah
okay we're going that route now
already it's so early and already the
misogyny
observation
no it's not so much that I wasn't even
looking at that um I was actually like
the um the camera is like it's kind of
awkward to move because it's a little
bit too big for the table and like the
ring light is in the way and [__] like
that so you can't get it like actually
in the regular like right in the middle
even if you wanted to
uh unless you move the ring light back
which I'm not going to do don't [__]
with it don't [__] with it
right there
oh so you [__] me up
there you go now now I feel better you
feel better now better now yeah
yeah if it's like you got some [__]
OCD issues I think
the Earth has settled down okay kind of
found his proper access to spin on well
that's that's good yeah that's good my
OCD or something yeah
all right
but yeah so uh it's Labor Day at least
if you're in the United States so
hopefully some of y'all had the day off
we uh went out last night so we're kind
of oh man we're kind of wiped out we
need to come back to like three
something bubbles four yeah I think it
was like 3 30 in the morning when we got
home and it's like then we woke up well
I woke up like earlier than you did I
think but yeah it still probably wasn't
enough sleep I never really quite woke
up I never did either we had a good time
though yeah you know danced a lot and
whatnot
um but yeah so a couple nights ago when
did we watch this movie Saturday night I
think so yeah yeah we were scrolling
through I guess it was Amazon Prime yeah
um we had both seen the Mist before a
long time ago
um but yeah I hadn't seen it for many
many years and Tom's like oh you know I
wouldn't mind re-watching that and I was
like yeah that sounds pretty good I
haven't seen it in a really long time
I've seen it once I've read The novella
but I haven't read the novella for like
a quite a long time either yeah I read a
long time it was in a collection a bunch
of stories it was in um skeleton Creole
and then like I think later on after the
movie came out I think they released it
like as a standalone but I first read it
in skeleton career so I've read it a
couple times now the movie does take
some liberties
but not a lot though
um well the ending is different and a
couple of the characters are different
but honestly I I feel like when this
came out this is one of those movies
that when it came out back in 2007
um the reviews of it were real mixed
like some people were into it some
people were it made money but not that
much like not as much as they were
expecting especially because Frank
Darabont had made a couple of other
Stephen King adaptations he made The
Green Mile didn't he make I thought he
made um Shawshank Redemption
um I can't remember if he made that one
or not but he made like a couple really
good ones that had done really well
and so when this one came out it didn't
do as well as those because it may be I
don't know why because it was more
straight up horror whereas the other
ones were dramas or whatever but
honestly I will say I think this is
actually one of the best Stephen King
adaptations absolutely
um that's among the classics like you
know yeah
um what's it uh [__]
uh Carey like the first yeah Christine
is definitely the first Dead Zone yeah
you know you could shining up you could
say The Shining that's Kubrick and it's
not it it's that story from the from a
different perspective
I kind of like
but it's you know I mean it's not quite
in the same tone tonally as this this
thing is a straight horror movie and
it's the same tone as the as the story
pretty much that's that I mean I
remember when I saw it the first time I
saw it I don't think I saw it in the
theater not that I remember but um I
probably saw it on cable or rented it
like a year or two after it came out and
I remember being really I thought it was
really cool because when I read the
novella it um a lot of the scenes from
it were like just how I was picturing
them like in the movie
but um like I said they did change a lot
and I think that was kind of like the
ending of this which you know we're
gonna spoil so I mean this movie's you
know more than a decade old at this
point and that's like and I feel like
most people that would know anything
about the Miss like no
about the ending and everything but this
was one of those things where Frank
darabot
um put a different ending on it and
Stephen King was kind of like [__] man
why didn't I do that you know what I
mean like he actually really liked uh
the change that had been made because
this does have what is one of the most
soul-crushing endings in all of horror
Cinema and I was there for it because
normally it doesn't have to have a happy
ending you know what I mean like we were
talking about this the other day how you
know I'm not saying that I like horror
movies that just have like [__] up
miserable endings just for the sake of
it but if it goes with the whole tone of
the movie then it doesn't have to have
you know the monster doesn't have to be
defeated at the end or you know it
doesn't have to be like oh everything's
okay now or [__] like that like you can
end it in a real [__] up way and this
definitely does I'm kind of mixed about
the ending I mean I liked the ending
that they showed but the book ending
it was they left you hanging they got
away and then they just disappeared into
the mist and something walked over the
car and that's that's how it ended you
didn't know what happened to him that's
how I remembered it yeah you did the
ending of The novella is much more
ambiguous but it's also a lot more
hopeful like I don't think like in the
novella you don't actually find out
um what happened to David's wife yeah
you don't find that out and you don't
find out if they get away like they
basically just drive off and I think
they hear something over the radio that
thinks like oh maybe there's people
alive and we can head that direction but
that's it yeah because I I like the
original ending because it made you
think that maybe king would do a sequel
to it and tell you what had happened
yeah and I was looking forward to that
um this one
and you see you kind of wanted more more
stories about what happened once the
Mist took over I wanted several books
like that something like long lines of
Gunslinger right well yeah because you
could expand this because you could have
a whole universe it's very well it's
very lovecraftian so you could basically
kind of like build it out in that sense
so in my mind this is the world had
changed and it was never changing back
in this one they shut the damn
dimensional portal and the military
evidently saved the day which I thought
was kind of corny it was it would have
been better if the Earth was destroyed
basically that the Mist had merged in
with it I liked that ending better I
mean I like both endings and I can see
um you know the case being made for
either one so I'm not gonna like argue
that people that like didn't like the
ending of the movie I really like the
ending of the movie because I thought it
was ballsy they don't usually end movies
like that and I was like and I respect
that he like was not afraid to go there
I would prefer to have that they had
killed themselves and the one God was
left and he you know he's Left Alive
because he ran out of ammunition and
then they saw the military
but the but the military was getting
annihilated that would have been better
right and then you know what I mean you
don't know what happens to him you know
what I mean he's just you just left like
that or maybe he's killed that would
have been a better ending maybe but the
whole thing about getting rid of the
Mist I was a bad idea because now you
can't do a sequel
to the movie well I mean you know they
probably or the book anyway yeah but
like I said the book they left it
ambiguous so you could still do like
something with the thing you just
couldn't do the film at it or you'd have
to like
you know for kind of finagle itself
what it's about it's about
um some people that end up getting
trapped in a Supermarket because this
mysterious fog Mist takes over
and people tried to leave and they got
killed by things out in the fog
there's some guys off duty military guys
in there
that are in the supermarket and come to
find out that their unit was the post
that they that they worked at was a
special kind of like research
laboratory unit and they had opened up a
dimensional window so they can look into
another dimension same [__] as
the people from stranger things opening
up those dimensional portals the problem
was that it wasn't the wind that was a
door you could go you could travel
between it and it was in a parallel
Earth
that never developed you know what I
mean it didn't develop like this one it
was more like a dinosaur
world with [__] crazy ass insects and
crazy ass [__] animals
it looked like something out of the
Earth or the dinosaur period but worse
like four-winged pterodactyls
that were real aggressive huge
mosquitoes looking things that were like
the size of a bird about the size of a
big bird and it had [__] scorpion
tails on them and had eyes that blinked
they were like they weren't insects in
fact animal eyes like compound eyes yeah
and uh and there were things that were
just you just see tentacles that opened
up into dab spikes it looked like
something on one of them damn blood
worms
um
there was other [__] but they you didn't
they didn't show it uh there's one thing
that walked across the road when they
drove out of there that had to have been
Maybe
seven eight stories tall the big six
legs I love that shot yeah it's almost
like a big gigantic dinosaur slash
elephant thing but then it had like all
those tentacles at the bottom like yeah
it was like uh like a six-legged
insect animal it's partially insect a
part animal it had a bunch of tentacles
on it
you could see it they didn't show its
head from what I remember not really not
sure it had like I said it almost kind
of had it it kind of gave me like the
impression of like a little bit of an
elephant kind of yeah kind of like a
little bit let's go yeah yeah yeah
that's kind of what I was thinking
uh October 8 said love the glasses Jen
thank you yeah I really like these I've
been wearing these for a while
um you know but and I had to order these
from like special because it's harder to
find like reading glasses that are the
shape I don't know why but whatever we
saw a girl
um working at a cafe who had glasses
that size but they were heart-shaped
yeah yeah she works she works at the
cafe at um at Books-A-Million like in
the Joe mugs and they're heart-shaped
but she's funny because they're super
super thick they're like they coke
bottle glasses like that but they're
heart-shaped she's like yeah my vision
is really bad she says yeah she's like
one of the furry says that yeah she's
like a little skinny nerdy girl kind of
reminds you like a female Andrew
Eldridge if she was a teenager oh yeah a
little bit you know someone that kind of
has that kind of face yeah she does yeah
yeah she's super cute
um but yeah so yeah so when we were
watching this movie now Frank Darabont
when he made this because he'd been
wanting to adapt this since like the 80s
right
um and he pictured it in black and white
now because obviously the studio is not
going to let you make it a black or
white but if you get the um we don't
have the Blu-ray but if you get the the
DVD or the Blu-ray there is a black and
white version on there and I have seen
clips of The Black and White Version and
I can totally see why
um he wanted to do it black away because
it looks really cool yeah in black and
white especially like the shots where
people like are just walking into the
Mist probably would be cool yeah it
looks really good the animals look
really [__] cool though the CG the CG
holds up you could tell CG but it holds
up the weird thing about it though and
it's like and K and B I'm pretty sure
did the effects with like Greg nicotero
in them
um
I saw like behind the scenes Clips when
I was you know researching the movie and
they built all of that stuff like they
had the bugs and they had the tentacles
and it was all like life-size but then
when you see it in the movie it's like
it looks like CGI yeah so I don't know
if they just like used
the the Practical and then like did CGI
over it yeah or use CGI to like enhance
it because it does it looked like they
built all that stuff like they had all
the tentacles like mixture stuff it
might have been
it doesn't look perfect it looks good
though but it still looks good you know
for that time period there's a scene
where they go into a
into a pharmacy
and these uh parallel universe
prehistoric [__] spiders they're kind
of like a colony like ants
and they range from the size of a real
spider like the babies
to the size of a [__]
grapefruit to the size of a cat to
bigger than a man they get got bigger
than a man I'd say
um
maybe 10 foot
leg span on them they're big big you
know bigger than a denim
[__] Alaskan crab you know those
things down the deep sea crabs are
bigger than that
and they uh
they impregnated one dude and they were
eating them alive the inside of them
kind of like that thing from squirm
it can make webs they'd [__] hemmed
up at these webs hanging
and they were live in there some of them
which is kind of like it's kind of like
alien like when they found him like with
all the nuts you know yeah the bigger
ones could shoot a web out of their
abdomen that was a long string a line it
was acidic if it landed on you and just
lay you right open down to the bone
[__] skin and slide off it was as a
and that's the way it was in the in the
book and they [__] captured it
perfectly how dangerous something like
that would be and then the weird thing
about it when you look at them they look
like something that can really exist
when you when you show them they're kind
of familiar
looking they're kind of crab-like too
uh but they had eyes that blinked yeah
none of them had compound eyes like an
insect they had eyes like an animal like
a like a mammal
or a [__] bird it look it was
effective it was a very effective
uh design for the creature designs that
you could buy that something like that
would exist in a parallel universe yeah
I mean when you're designing a like a
monster or a creature for a horror movie
it's always good to use actual creatures
yes but just kind of like mix and match
yeah you know what I mean or pick like
super weird ones and stuff like that and
kind of mix and match like attributes
because you know there is stuff that has
all of those attributes that actually do
exist just maybe not all of a sudden
yeah what made sense you know in the
other universe it's still basically the
dinosaur age of the dinosaur basically
but all these primitive creatures have
evolved it's still the same year it's
still you know 2020 or whatever when it
just come out 2006 2007 2007 so 2007
it's just a parallel 2007 and the
insects have [__] evolved to have
you know those these particular insects
to evolve [__] have advanced traits
including mammalian type eyes
that would be [__] bizarre and then
you had things that were like
pterodactyls but they had four wings
like a
like a dragonfly no that would probably
work maybe I think that might work I
don't know if you'd need four it was
hovering though kind of like the way it
dragged and turned and like the way a
dragonfly would so yeah that's a pretty
good design
you know I don't know if there's no it's
possible in nature but it looks like
it'd be possible we're going on two eggs
we were watching the movie and they
first have that
scene where you know they're all in the
grocery store and like the bugs start
like hitting against the glass and
everything and it's like we were making
jokes like we live in Florida we've seen
bugs that big
big deal go to Circle K and the whole
side of a couple of Mayflower yeah
that's it when I was a kid it was in
Mississippi it was more like that
um I don't know if it's insecticides or
if it was just the areas built built up
more I I think it might be insecticides
every in the summertime every [__]
parking lot light and every [__]
store window was just covered with
[__] bugs trying to fight to get
their way in just
uh [__] what were those things
cicadas were one of them
everybody bug zappers and all night I
don't know why you had bug zappers I
guess it was yeah we had entertainment
we had them too you sit there and just
yeah you just sit there and sit out
there on the porch and smoke and watch
all the movies they had a blue light on
them that would attract every [__]
bug for a mile and you just kill them
all right yeah
the big big pile of [__] flying
insects underneath it with frogs eating
the [__] bugs that were falling
Frog's fat as [__] did you have a
collection of frogs underneath them yeah
yeah they just like sit down there going
they just killed them all out
the main ones I remember was [__] uh
moths was one of them yeah and then uh I
just mostly remember cicadas
yeah yeah
how funny would it have been like if in
the Mist they like started hanging like
no pest strips like outside the grocery
store and [__] like that every now and
then those big beetles like a Japanese
beetles
and then uh you'd hear back and you look
and there'd be a big old [__]
palmetto bug big cockroach because they
fly yeah they fly try to fly up into it
if it can get electrocuted you know
what's even bigger in Florida you know
it's even bigger than the palmetto bugs
are those water bugs yeah holy [__]
that off they're big you don't but
they're horrifying yeah every now and
then like after a rainstorm or something
you'll be walking through the parking
lot and see one like in a puddle and
you'll be like they're gigantic those
giant [__] black locusts with all the
with the yellow stripes the yellow red
stripes on I saw one of those in our uh
driveway yeah just a couple days ago
those things used to be so common when I
was a kid you don't see them yeah we
says my grandmother used to like pick
them off I have to pick them off her
plants because they would just eat your
plants yeah you know what I mean just
eat big holes in them yeah
but yeah so um but yeah so I hadn't seen
this movie in a really long time and I
forgot how [__] good this movie was
like all the acting is amazing like the
ensemble cast in this is incredible also
I forgot how many [__] from The
Walking Dead were on this yeah which
like I said Walking Dead yeah half The
Walking Dead is in this movie well like
because you know it's Frank derebonne
and he was like the showrunner for the
first I don't know how many seasons was
he the showrunner for who Frank garabon
the guy that directed this movie he was
the showrunner for The Walking Dead like
um for the first few seasons right so
it's like six seasons yeah yeah the good
ones yeah
um yeah Andrea is in this yeah uh Carol
is in this like Jeffrey Dumont is in
this
um and actually I had forgotten that
Carol was that she's not in it like a
lot she's just at the very beginning and
like at the very end do you see there
again in Boston I think was [__]
wasn't he from Boston
yeah towards the end I think he was some
somebody in one of those groups he might
have been he did a real good job and uh
yeah that was an interesting character
he thought people were [__]
lying to him about what was out there is
in denial he didn't think there's any
monsters out there
see that well that's the great thing
about this movie is that yeah like
obviously it's like really bad that like
there's monsters out there that will
[__] tear you in half and [__] like
that but the real horror of it is all of
the people
inside and like the little factions that
they and the fact that like when it
first happens like they you know the
guys go in the back and they see that
bad boy get taken away by this [__]
tentacles you know what I mean that's
like the first thing they see and then
they go back in the front and they're
like we hate to tell you this but
tentacles and everybody's like [__]
which I guess you wouldn't yeah I mean
you can go back here and look at the
tentacle because well yeah I think like
deep down they were probably like oh
[__] I don't like I don't want to know
like they don't they didn't want it to
be confirmed you know what I mean
but
um but yeah so one of the differences I
think one of the main differences in the
movie like uh from the movie to the
novella other than the ending obviously
um is the character of uh Mrs Carmody
yeah now she is a great Marcia Gay
Harden is great in this movie she she
she could almost come across because
she's so like over the top like crazy
she could almost come across as like a
caricature but she totally does not like
she's totally believable in this uh in
this she's she's a she's immensely ill
definitely a mentally ill oh big time uh
a chick who's like uh real bible thumper
like a fundamentalist not a real
fundamentalist she's not even quoting
scripture she's making scripture she's
just pulling out her [__] that's crazy
yeah and uh she thinks it's [__]
basically this is God's wrath upon him
and nobody believes her first but as the
situation gets worse and worse she
starts getting a whole damn cult
following her and then she's telling
them that she's getting messages
directly from God you know so because it
goes like a Jim Jones because that's the
thing she does correctly predict some
[__] yeah yeah so that kind of makes
everybody be like oh well maybe she's on
to something you know what I mean as as
[__] gets crazier and crazier because
obviously if you're in that situation
yeah like like I totally believe it like
half of the people maybe not fully half
but maybe like close to half of the
people would probably yeah go in that
because they couldn't [__] deal with
it like the reality of it and they'd
just be like oh well yeah this must be
like some biblical yeah and the people
that are in there are just Supermarket
employees so they're not they're not
trained for any kind of leadership and
the military guys that in their flunky
military they're just privates and
they're not
they're they're kind of like Tech guys I
think the tech and support type guys
so they don't really have that they're
not old enough or they don't really have
the gravel tiles to take charge and try
to get [__] done I think it wasn't the
main dude was not the manager but that
was the assistant manager that was the
guy with the gun yeah the assistant
manager I think he was the assistant
manager his boss to shut the [__] up
because he was just incompetent really
um
so they just kind of
the natural leaders kind of rise up
that's the main character he was an
author wasn't he uh no he was an art
like a poster artist remember yeah yeah
he was the poster artist and the
assistant manager
and uh
I think the other guys where it was they
had a couple mechanics with them they
had a biker with him he got killed
remember he got torn in half yeah he he
uh he said yeah they pulled back just
his legs yeah that was [__] great
look around him and he walked he was
trying to uh go out there and he's to go
get a truck and drive it back around and
he he says put a rope on me so you at
least know how far I got he didn't get
that far and then the Rope went up so
whatever God had [__] took him up in
the air that was a great [__] must
have been that something like throwing
the big tall things with all the damn
yeah six legs and then they pull it back
and the Rope comes back and it's just
like blood blood and then it's just legs
legs that's great lower torso like it
was a fantastic hanging out yeah this is
here take this with you and hand him a
little knife and he pulls out a big ass
[__] no I'm good Chloe knife he says
I'm good but it didn't dude yeah he was
Brave but killed
well most of the people got killed and
to be honest with you because there's
not really any way you could fight that
like super effectively and there was
also um there's a lot of um King it was
like this in the book King actually kind
of did his homework on personality types
and um
there's a bunch of psycho psychological
uh things happen when you have [__]
people
in an emergency situation they
a lot of people just wait for a rescue
uh and and they just and they continue
to follow rules that they were given
even though those rules no longer apply
they show that quite
you know oh you can't do that you know
it might be lawsuits man it's the end of
the [__] world you know whatever yeah
that one lawyer guy he was like I'm
gonna see you [__] too yeah yeah
and um it's like no one's suing anything
yeah and they're not real they're
civilians and they're not really
experienced and uh things like as soon
as that woman started to get gain a
follower they just should have killed
her or yeah you could have done that but
I was like yeah you need to nip that
right in the bud yeah because that was
going to be a problem that's going to
end badly you can just go out and kill
her in front of everybody and say I run
this [__] you can't do that and people
will just go oh okay they won't Rebel
history shows it over and over and over
do you know that pretty much every like
screening of this like when uh you know
Toby Jones's character his name is Ali
when he finally is just like has enough
of her [__] and just like shoots her in
the head like everybody
it was
it was [__] like I said
there was no loss and she was a threat
to everybody so you should just go well
she was gonna sacrifice yeah the main
guy's kid yeah and they killed a dude
she she ended up killing a dude yeah and
she stabbed like the soldier guy and
they're gonna throw him outside as like
a sacrifice yeah he was going that way
you could have nipped it in the bud
before it is any innocent people were
killed and if you didn't want to [__]
take her out yourself [__] Walking
Dead style they could have just banished
her out into that fog that's what I
think I would have done because then
because she's sitting there going oh we
need to sacrifice I'm like okay I
nominate you get your [__] ass out of
here yeah you go get it let God save you
how about that damn [__] scorpion
bugs get her yeah
yeah because the dudes that walked out
what I did like because I didn't
remember this in the book
when they ended up out in the parking
lot to get the truck to get to get one
of the uh to get the Jeep to get out of
there some but people got killed just
getting to the vehicle yeah but they saw
what happened to the black guy in his
party who just walked out of there the
[__] spiders got him yeah they were
up there [__]
oh little spiders glued to the cars
basically [__] then the spiders were
hatching it or [__] laying eggs in
them and I forgot that one scene too
where the guy like falls off the wall
and all the spiders like bust out I was
like ah that was like [__] great I
totally forgot I don't think I don't
think in the book you ever find out what
happened to him they were just [__]
killed yeah like I said I think a lot of
streaming out there and that was it I
the the novella leaves a lot of things
ambiguous like I said I don't think in
the um in the book I don't think he
mentions where the Mist came from I
think there is a mention of the
arrowhead project which they do talk
about in the movie but in the book but
it yeah they do mention it but they
don't really they don't go into detail
about he doesn't go into detail about
like um oh they opened a dimensional
Rift or anything like that but in the
movie they do and in the movie they say
you know that's what it was it was the
military they were up on the hill they
were doing this weird project they
opened an interdimensional portal yeah I
seem to remember that that there was
enough in the book to let you know what
was happening yeah it was just implied
they didn't really like he didn't really
stain at all I always pictured it that
they opened up that door and in the in
the parallel world it's just a big Mist
that's the atmosphere and it was just
pouring out of that Dam
dimension door
and creatures were coming through it too
bugs
bugs and [__] huge if the door must
have get must have gotten bigger and
bigger because some of those creatures
were huge
yeah yeah so
they must have just split a rift in the
Two Worlds merged
you know because maybe the maybe the
door just kept getting bigger and bigger
yeah and it's just gonna take it yeah
and it's just gonna like take over this
universe world I mean if it's
lovecraftian we get yeah the uh The
Faded Line just said Lovecraft inspired
for sure oh yeah big time
um yeah that would probably just
eventually like take over the whole yeah
Earth under the impression of reading
the book that the whole world was being
taken over that's like kind of the
impression that I got too
because I think some of the characters
were saying basically that what that
project Arrowhead oh it might just you
know the door just might continue to
stay open or get bigger or something
like that I think the doors got bigger
yeah it would just get bigger and bigger
and so right yeah
yeah uh Ben is talking about Mrs Carmody
and says was she crazy if she was right
I'm really right well she okay she was
able to predict some things but it
wasn't because she had a direct line to
Jesus or nothing like that it just so
happened that she predicted a few things
that were right and honestly she was
even then it's like she she didn't know
anything about like it was nothing to do
with like God doing it or nothing like
that right project or anything
so even if she was right it was just
like incidental she didn't really know
it was and she had one of the soldiers
killed for it even though he was
innocent he was he didn't have anything
to do with it he just worked there yeah
they just they just used him as a
scapegoat because she was like he must
know all about it like he worked up
there he's like bro it's like I just
[__] I didn't I didn't know [__]
about [__] you know what I mean I just
worked in a little facility that had
nothing to write an experiment it was
just a support unit for the for it yeah
and they weren't sure what it was they
were working on and that's you know and
that happens with anything like you
can't just blame one person like that
because it's like they probably didn't
know what the [__] was going on
he was just like a low level like flunky
you know what I mean they didn't know
anything the Manhattan Project he was so
compartmentalized he had thousands of
people in a basically a [__]
artificial City and none of them knew
what they were working on that's what I
mean well and usually if you're working
on something super top secret they
usually have you on a need to know basis
so it's like every bit there's really no
there's hardly anybody that work in
those things that know everything that's
going on you just know what you're
working on you don't know what like the
big picture is yeah and they do that
like deliberately yeah Kalyn Higgin said
a broken clock is right twice a day
exactly and I liked that they did that
because actually Mrs Carmody is a very
different character in the movie than
she is in the book like in the book I
don't she wasn't like a fundamentalist
Christian type like an Old Testament
kind of person she was kind of like
um she was almost kind of like an old
like new eight not new Agee but she was
kind of like a almost like an old like a
witch and she was old she was like an
old lady
and the same kind of [__] happened but
it wasn't exactly the same it didn't
have that fundamentalist she was veneer
to it she was merging
she was merging Bible verses together to
to make them mean things that she wanted
to me she was making stuff up just
sounded biblical yeah it was it's not
from the Bible although I have to say my
favorite line in the whole movie is what
she said
to Lori Holden's character who I just
keep calling Andrea because she was
Andrew in The Walking Dead but um you
know because Andrea is like sitting
there going it's like oh you know if you
need a friend or I'll be your friend or
something like that and Mrs Carmody said
if I need a friend like you I'll just
have a little Squat and [__] one out
yeah I was like damn that is some cold
but I'm gonna have to remember that
though just in case I might need that
line sometime you know what I mean but
um that's not in the book that was a
that was in the early edition in the
book everybody in town knew her as a
lunatic she was crazy yeah yeah right
and I kind of feel well that's kind of
implied in the movie too because doesn't
one guy say to the other guy like in the
grocery store they're like yeah that's
just because she's kind of a nut like
everybody kind of knows everybody like
everybody like nobody really likes her
but like I said if you're in a situation
like that where it seems like the world
has just gone [__] crazy and all of
this crazy [__] is happening that you
didn't think was possible then yeah they
suddenly the crazy person is gonna sound
a lot more reasonable because she's
saying you know she's saying [__] that
it's like kind of sounds like oh well
maybe this is biblical maybe this is the
end of the world yeah if you haven't
seen
she's not
she's religious but it's it's her own
religion she's making [__] up it's based
on the Bible but that she's making up
versus the great thing about her
character and like I said Marcia Gay
Harden killed it in this movie she's so
[__] great I think her performance
was my favorite
um out of the whole out of all the
characters but the thing about her was
that she was supposedly
super Christian super fundamentalist
super but she was an [__] like some
of the [__] she said was just she was
just mean spirited and awful and it's
just kind of and I like that they that
she pulled off that juxtaposition that
character and I like I said I totally
bought it you know I so thankfully I'd
never met anybody like that in real life
but there are people like that in real
life she is just a deeply deeply shitty
person but she thinks she's awesome I
mean there's a scene of her where she's
like praying and she's talking to God or
whatever with nobody else around
and she basically says you know most of
these people can't be saved like you
know because they suck and so so she's
obviously thinks that she's the be-all
end-all like the Arbiter of who deserves
to be saved and who doesn't like she
generally she genuinely thinks that she
has a direct line to God that she's like
the bestest jesusiest black person ever
and she has the right to like judge
everyone else so yeah so she is very
very clearly like a lunatic and like you
said and I think that it's good that
somebody mentioned Jim Jones in there
because that's exactly like what she was
like yeah they mentioned Jim Jones in a
movie yeah we got our own Jen Jones here
yeah exactly yeah we did a show about
that a while back if you have if you
don't know about this kind of thing you
can see recordings of him talking to his
people and he sounded very magnanimous
and real [__] uh powerful and [__]
but he's just he's just [__] he's
full of [__] you know yeah
gets all those [__] people to drink
the Kool-Aid including the kids
see that's the thing [__] failed I mean
that's the thing I'm always just kind of
like look everybody on this Earth
is you know none of us know [__] we're
just human beings we're all flawed no if
somebody comes to you and says they have
the answers to [__] do not listen to
that person like because they do not
nobody that's Jim Jones though I think
will happen with him I don't think he
was started off as crazy
he didn't he he was he he got depressed
started getting all the [__] pills
and drugs and they went and then and
then he went okay yeah because everybody
I saw like a very depressing documentary
about it and they and they use like all
of the um
all of the recordings and so because
they recorded everything which I didn't
realize so there's tons of like audio
recordings and film and all this good
because they recorded everything they
were doing so I saw this document and I
went to like a little Art House theater
and saw it and it was one of the most
sole crushing things I've ever seen but
it's just kind of like the sad thing is
it started out
um they started out very
well-intentioned and everything started
out like normal like it didn't seem
culty at first but then it just kind of
start so you know and anybody that
studies Cults any great degree and I
think this movie kind of shows that too
like it's a very organic thing like how
it could happen especially in a
situation yeah you know that's that's
extraordinary because you're always
going to get a certain percentage of
people that need direction because they
don't because they don't know what to do
and so they're always like looking to
somebody else like to help them or save
them or something like that and that's
kind of like a dangerous thing and I
think this movie does a good job of like
um portraying that yeah and the main
character uh
did a pretty good job of realizing that
look most these people ain't gonna make
it they're [__] let's just get the
best people we can and let's get the
[__] out of here
and they got killed getting out of there
but that was really the best course of
action you couldn't stay in there but
the thing about it would and that's
another thing that I kind of liked
because they're they're saying like how
[__] up the ending was which it is but
it's like and I had forgotten this app I
remembered the ending I mean this ending
is like really uh it's hard to forget
you know what I mean because like I said
it's it's a pretty [__] gut punch of
an ending but I had forgotten that there
was another just another little twist of
the knife in there and that was that the
woman like at the beginning of the movie
you know who played Carol on The Walking
Dead yeah she was the first one to leave
and it's like they didn't want her to
leave they're like Lady it's like super
dangerous out there it's like that guy
just came in and said there's monsters
out in the mist and it's like people are
getting killed and she's like but you
know I have to get back to my kids I you
know I said I was gonna come right back
and they're too little to be left alone
and she walks out and they never say
what happened to her but then at the end
after spoiler alert uh you know David
kills his son and you know the the two
old people and the and the lady and then
like shows up the military everything's
fine one of the trucks that goes by with
all the refugees has her and her kids on
it yeah they made it and that and and I
was like oh man I forget that is [__]
up I forgot about it yeah there there's
a there's a um like a psychological
phenomenon I forgot what it was called
the exact term I think it's called
stress induced delayed inertia some [__]
like that it's where you're in in a
group of people getting like the Donner
Party had this yeah a group of people
get into a jam
and they're they're they either have a
choice of stay put and try to survive
what's ever happening wait for rescue or
to leave
if they leave the longer they wait to
leave the the more the more their
chances of failure increase because
they're steadily getting weaker and
weaker and weaker and weaker and they're
the group's getting smaller and smaller
and they're getting more and more
desperate
and that woman kind of passed that test
the missed hit she had kids at the home
she said I'm getting the [__] out of
here
before it got too bad I mean she might
have gotten killed she didn't know but
she's like I'm I can't stay here and but
you definitely would have got killed had
you left later right and that that
that's something that you you people as
civilians and [__] should take I've
called people civilians you people you
people or something you were also a
civilian yeah I'm a civilian now too I
don't see myself as a civilian
um
in an emergency situation direct direct
and Speedy action always beats
the best laid plan executed too late
right so when you ever get a jam you
work you do go right now
if anybody ever tries to capture or
abduct you you try to escape right now
because wherever that person's taking
you you're going to be too weak to
escape when you get there
well [__] that's what I was just
listening to where it was one of the
scary stories things the other day
and they were basically saying the same
thing like everybody knows this now but
it's like look if you're gonna get kid
don't ever let anybody take you to a
second location do whatever the [__] you
have to do you fight you scream you do
something you force that dude to kill
you do not let them take you someplace
else because you are not gonna make it
nope and he's gonna he's gonna kill you
and it's gonna take a lot longer you
ain't gonna like it yeah I mean just do
whatever you got to do just don't let
nobody take you anywhere yeah and I kind
of feel like I don't you know obviously
hopefully I'm never going to be in a
situation like in the midst where I'm
trapped in a grocery store and there's
lovecraftian monsters like stomping
around outside but I like to think that
I would have done what Carol did I don't
even remember what her character what
her character name was in this movie I'm
just calling her Carol because that's
what she wasn't Walking Dead but um I
think I would have been like yeah I'm
with you sister well and the thing about
it is that she asked other people to
come with her and nobody would
everybody's like nah we're just gonna
stay right here and she's like well [__]
it you know my kids are at home I gotta
go and like you didn't know what
happened to her for the whole movie and
then at the end like I like I said I had
forgotten about that that she made it
and her kids made it she made it back
because the Mist had just hit and the
spiders hadn't taken over the parking
lot yet right and you had to go through
the parking lot
spiders must took up took over the
parking lot by by the time the black guy
and his group left
yeah which wasn't that much longer
because they didn't actually believe
there was anything out there
I don't think they were in there that
long were they
they slept a couple times and woke up
so it was several days maybe it was then
well I'm just talking about like the the
lawyer and the and his group when they
left yeah maybe it was like a day later
like the day after or something like
that the Andrea chick she left the same
day
she left that day
yeah like pretty much as soon as the
Mist rolled in yeah she's like yeah no
I'm not having it and the monster's head
from the Mist hadn't taken over the
parking lot and I guess parts of the
surrounding area that you had to go
through to get to her house now when
dude when the main character he he gets
in the car when they escape he drives by
his house and the house had a hole in it
because the day before because there was
a storm storm yeah and the storm I guess
was created by opening up the rift yeah
that's what it that's what the
implication was they didn't say that
outright but yeah and uh the tree hit
the side of the house and busted the
window in and he was going to the to
store it again to the store to get them
like you know what I mean plastic to
[__] tape it up to cover that up
and a couple days later when he was able
to escape
the supermarket and go back home drives
by the house and he looks into the hole
in that window and sees his wife webbed
up against the wall and spiders got her
full of spiders and he's like they got
into the hole in the wall and the hole
in the window
so but the thing is is those [__]
things were pretty heavy I don't think
any sheet plastic could keep them out
but still I mean but that was like real
that was real heart-wrenching too
because it's like he blamed himself even
though it probably closed the door in
that room
barricade that room well maybe she
didn't know what's going on or maybe it
was too late like by the time she
figured it out yeah yeah they don't
really like say because you're not
really expecting I mean like a Miss
comes in you're like oh look like a
weird Mist you're not expecting [__]
monsters yeah maybe crawling around in
there spiders were in there she just
right like why would you assume that
yeah
spider was on the bed that's what I mean
it's like oh my God you would shake your
[__] pants and took her back into
that room and webbed her up
another thing they left out of the movie
and I'm kind of glad they did because I
didn't love this in the book
but um the character the main character
his name is David his name is David
Drayton right um
and him and the Andrea lady they [__]
yeah like because they're like you know
even though he does he never finds out
like what happened to his wife if you
assume that she died but that he doesn't
say that because like you never find out
like if his wife is dead or alive
in the novel in the in the movie you do
but um but yeah in the book they're kind
of like stressed out and everything like
that and they end up having like a
quickie or some [__] like that and I'm
just kind of like I can see why Frank
Darabont like left that out of them it's
I don't know I just don't think that
totally would have been really good like
I said I didn't love it in the book
either but it you know it flew more in
the book I guess but they'd left that
out of the movie and I'm kind of glad
they did like they kind of um you know
they kind of like had a friendship and
she was kind of like a surrogate mom
like to the kid I was gonna say too and
I'm not usually like a big fan of child
actors although there's a lot of good
ones around nowadays the kid in this
killed it he was great
and I for I forgot like what the what
the kid's name was what the actor was
but some of the scenes like especially
when when his dad like comes and says
he's gonna go to the pharmacy like to
help the guy that got burned you know
what I mean like we need to go next door
to the pharmacy and get the stuff like
to help him or whatever and it's like
when he said and when he's having that
conversation with his kid it's like you
know I'm gonna come back and all this
other stuff I mean that kid that was
like really holy [__] that kid was great
that kid was great it's a good movie
yeah like I said I forgot how good it
was
um stood the test of time I own this
movie yeah
and because I kind of want to I kind of
wanted to get the Blu-ray or the um the
Blu-ray because I think it has the black
and white version on it and I actually
do like the black and white version yeah
because that I mean the way that it's
shot
um especially like the outside scenes
like I said you see these people like
just going into the midst and like
disappearing that almost kind of looks
like black and white anyway
um just because you know there's the
color is kind of like leeched out of it
and stuff but I don't know yeah I think
the the black and white does look like
really good like just from the scenes of
it I've seen I've never watched the
whole thing in black and white but I've
seen like scenes of it
uh yeah Tammy said yeah even if he knew
his wife had died he certainly didn't
mourn for long yeah I think that was
what bothered me about it I'm like dude
it's only been like a day or two would
you like put it back in your [__]
pants and it's just kind of like look
we're being attacked by monsters your
wife could still be alive for all you
know and she could you know be waiting
for you to come back and you're just
like [__] this random chicken like
the back of a grocery store King did
that a lot he did that's what I was
thinking I was like there must be some
weird fetish that he has what it was I
think what it was and I remembered a lot
of books being like this from that era
back when I used to read oral as a kid
it's a pre-internet back when I used to
read
there always had to be sex scenes and
yeah that's right so you have to include
a sex scene so you just gotta write that
in there because they were popular
they'd sold books right so it's not
people reading into this [__] oh well
he must have some weird [__] with no
he's fulfilling market and stuff yeah I
get that yeah but I I like that there
that now you don't they don't really
feel the need It's like because I do
kind of feel like for a while
um you know even like in the 70s and 80s
and stuff like that I feel like even
horror movies they always had to
shoehorn in like a romance subplot or a
sex scene or something and I'm like that
doesn't need to be in there it's like
you know for the time well I know I'll
tell you why it did for the time because
in the you know Stephen King as a
household name and something mainstream
that has female fans and [__] like that
back in the day the main readers were
young males yeah and kind of nerdy right
kind of like horror nerds so they wanted
to read some porn and the girls that
were reading they got some quarantine
you know women love [__] written
eroticas so they put that in there
although
he's not riding erotica for females
he's not writing a romance novel you
know but uh that's more targeted towards
he's he's just trying he knows it's like
a movie he knows who the audience is of
that time back in the 70s 80s whatever
yeah they had they had to have a fight
they had to put sex in yeah so they
always had to like she weren't in like
just like every [__] even if it didn't
have anything to do with it yeah every
[__] movie that they knew teenage
guys were gonna watch had titties in it
well yeah they were just like why are we
watching this yeah it's like what's the
point yeah there's no boobs right you
take it for granted today in the age of
the internet that porn is something you
could access very easily but back in the
back when we were kids yeah nope so the
only action you got was maybe watching
some of the second horror movies made
for teens and [__] you know [__] you
can watch Galaxy a terror and see a girl
get sexually molested by a gigantic
[__] caterpillar
if that's your favorite oh man that's
hot there's there's a movie there's a
movie yeah there's a movie for you
if you haven't seen Roger corman's
Galaxy of Terror yeah if you ever wanted
to see a naked woman get uh molested by
a gigantic slimy caterpillar yeah he's
about 40 feet long then uh that's the
that's the movie that movie is actually
a good movie that's special effects are
great and the special effects are done
by James Cameron that's right before he
before he was famous
you know on the back of [__] Galaxy
of Terror that's how he got the gig for
[__] aliens like alien too and if you
see you can see it's well made it's like
alien too
it is yeah it's good it had some hokey
[__] in it
because there's a Karma flick but it
looked tight that sick
Aaron Moran from Happy Days yeah yeah
she was that it you can get it on
Blu-ray they got special releases for it
it it's it's a cool watch I like that
movie horror movies I mean it's not my
favorite I mean my favorite Roger cormo
ones are the Edgar Allan Poe adaptations
but um Galaxy of Terror is a good one
yeah yeah even though you know he made
it as a rip-off but it's kind of its own
thing yeah it's a ripoff of alien yeah
and it looks really good yeah I mean we
just reviewed it not too long ago
um Scott says I didn't even see the Mist
until six years ago thought it was
fantastic one of the better King films
oh yeah I definitely agree
um and then uh The Faded Line recommends
the endless a great indie film that's
Lovecraft Style with the whole cult
situation yeah that's a great [__]
movie honestly I watched it
probably three or four years ago because
when did it come out 2016 2017 something
like that and I remember really liking
it but I definitely think it's time for
like a re-watch maybe I'll do it over on
my um on my um flickers of fear thing
because I have been wanting to re-watch
it uh Scott says have you guys seen the
name list the Spanish film based on
Ramsay Campbell's novel it's not bad no
I don't think I have I've read a lot of
Ramsay Campbell I like him as well but
um but yeah I didn't know about that
movie so I'll have to look that up uh
then Scott says even a ghost story the
guy's screwing a ghost yeah pretty much
yeah pretty much uh and also says that
girl from Life Force hell I'd screw a
space vampire yeah yeah she's super hot
I want to buy that movie I want to have
life force I want to get like a good
steel book yeah Toby Hooper if you guys
don't yeah
very good
excellent low budget flick
um but it's real well made
yeah I think it was a British movie
technically wouldn't it uh it might have
been he was might have been like the
crew might have been yeah and I saw the
uh the conceptual art for it it was
gonna be even cooler
spaceships that look like big [__]
coffins and [__] yeah you know which if
I was a space vampire I would totally
have this Facebook like a coffin oh yeah
I would go
the straight up space vampire root they
just went well she's an alien being you
know what I mean but [__] they didn't
give her vampy qualities you know
they're like well she just walks around
naked the whole time and everyone's just
like all right well let's roll with that
doesn't say a word because she the
actress can't speak English yeah a
little skinny for my taste but she was
she had a pretty face
super hot yeah well she was a dancer was
she not yeah I think she was she was
like Czech Slovakian or something she's
an Eastern European cute Eastern
European or French or cute I can't
remember we saw
um Brandon tunnel did a thing on
Vampirella I missed it it was [__]
what is that 1990 something it's a
[__] corny
if you guys grew up you know if you're a
Gen X or you know who Vampirella is or
some [__] comic books or some hot
[__] vampire chick basically wearing
a painted on bikini and [__] a white
collar black hair it was
he Goofs on the movie but it has some
solid vampire lore in it I want to see
it now I had totally forgotten that
Roger Daltrey was in that [__] yeah
Hamming it up man he chews the scene
just choose it
and spits it back out and then chews it
up again
some of the [__] that they showed in
this move in in Vampirella airhisha and
Vampirella you can definitely see that
[__] um blade ripped some of that off
the movie Blade which is another type
yeah because that came out a couple of
years after Vampirella yeah I kind of
feel like people forgot that they made
him I forgot that they made a movie in
the 90s of Vampirella to be honest with
you because it wasn't really that great
main problem with Vampirella from what
me and Jen saw is that her little
[__] vampire costume is [__] lame
as hell the bottom looks like she's got
diapers on it did yeah it wasn't great
it was not flattering and at all and she
she's a good looking woman but she's not
as [__] big as they were gonna have
another girl play Vampirella who look
like a porn star with [__]
get somebody with huge jugs yeah I mean
that's just what the character looks
like yeah and and she's got to be so
skimpily clad if that [__] Vampirella
outfit is like painted on that should
have been something we had a huge
discussion about what that costume
because like I said Brandon 10 old um
you know if you don't subscribe to
Brandon sandals Channel you should like
he's this Canadian dude and he does like
he puts up one thing a week I guess of
like just bad movies but he makes like
funny commentary about them and he just
put up on a Vampirella so me and Tom are
watching this and we're having this
humongous discussion about the costuming
choices and like who they should have
got and it's like what they should have
made the costume out of and [__] like
that it's really bad it's it just looks
really cheap it looks like just kind of
some cheap yeah like fake vinyl yeah and
like I said there's nothing wrong with
the actress like her face looked like
vampire yeah yeah like big time
um but she just didn't she wasn't like
she was kind of thin
um not flat but she's probably like a b
cup you know um and Vampirella was like
papow she had like huge double d tits
and her her costume was she's a cartoon
so it's so tight it's only like an inch
wide and it goes around across the top
of the nipples and then it goes down the
side and then it just goes around her
[__] little badge and [__] yeah it's
basically naked with boots and a collar
I mean it's it's like dental floss
pretty much like red tail she should
basically bend in a painted on bikini
yeah and with it with a little white
collar on it and it with the black hair
it would have been [__] great had it
been shot the right way there's rumors
that they somebody wanted to remake it
um and look if you're gonna have
somebody [__] if you're you gotta with
that [__] character you can't have a
normal actress she's got to be a full-on
top-notch porn star has to do that it's
the only girls that are built like that
it ain't natural it's got to be fun it's
like I said I mean you want her to look
like the character you want I mean
that's what the character looks like
yeah so it makes it look like spoiler I
believe she's a space vampire too
because she came in a spaceship and [__]
that's true yeah uh Scott says haunted
Palace is a good flick yes it is I
actually reviewed haunted Palace
a few months ago uh if you don't know
that had Vincent Price in it and even
though it was
touted as one of the Roger Corman Poe
cycle
um you know because they called it the
haunted Palace after one of Edgar Allan
Poe's poems but it's actually based on a
Lovecraft story I think it was the case
of Charles Dexter award which is what I
think but it's great if you haven't seen
it if you've seen like some other Roger
Corman movies or you know if you like
Vincent I mean who doesn't like Vincent
Price everybody likes Vincent Price but
it's like um it's really really good
like I reviewed it not too long ago but
yeah and it's also uh Lovecraft so even
this yeah Danica Patrick playing it yeah
Danica Patrick could have played
Vampirella yeah it's like there's
probably a lot of actresses that play
that but like I said it's if you're
gonna do it
you know Danica Patrick I believe is a
porn star yeah yeah yeah if you're gonna
do it like make her look like yeah
because you know I felt kind of bad you
know
somebody was talking about Roger Daltrey
too it's like Roger Daltrey like just
from the clips that they showed not the
Vampirella thing I mean he looked like
he was just like [__] Hamming it up
but we're trying to find that movie out
of watching but I was just kind of like
I was like I kind of is it bad that I
kind of want to watch this no I was like
this looks ridiculous and awesome
um but yeah and somebody mentioned that
Roger Daltrey was in the Legacy also
yeah that's right I own it yeah Tom
really likes that movie like I like that
movie too Roger Daltrey was in a lot of
stuff actually he does a good job in
that movie he does yeah he's not like
but like in this one he's just like a
cackling Vape like he's got big fangs
and yeah like a cape and [__] like that
like he looks like a classic vampire
Vampirella had an All-Star cast there
was a bunch of people in there we
recognized remember yeah because we were
just sitting there going oh my God that
[__] I totally forgot about that
that movie even existed yeah I forgot
that movie existed yeah it's just I mean
because it was the 90s it's like nobody
did like it would come and go people
were making comic book movies but they
didn't really take them seriously like
they do nowadays so it's like a lot of
them are just like really shitty yeah
um yeah Scott said I read the novel The
Legacy when it first came out I think I
might have two but I don't remember that
much about it because it was so long ago
that's a forgotten classic that's a
well-made movie I like that I like that
movie a lot yeah
whatever Road they take it comes back to
the [__] Castle [__] like that always
creeps me out because whenever they do
that in movies yeah yeah that didn't
have um yeah well Catherine Ross was at
it and she was in Stepford Wives the
original Separate Lives
um and also that was um what's his face
uh Grizzle little cowboy dude Sam
Elliott yeah yeah Sam Elliott
um young still had the big big stash
four stash big porn stash yeah or the
Tash yeah that's Johnny [__] case yeah
and it looks like it was filmed in
England so it left it had a real good
English [__] vibe to it guys what if
you haven't seen the Legacy see it's
about a woman who gets called to this
[__] meeting of all these [__]
Rich important people somewhere out in
England
and it turns out all these people are
witches and the this billionaire that's
dying is gonna [__] give some Legacy
to yeah
she doesn't realize it but she's
in line for the inheritance
these witches are all kill he's killing
all his subordinate witches and knocking
them out to [__] clean the Slate and
he's doing it using his mind Powers
they're kind of like Sith out of Star
Wars they they have mental witch powers
I like witches because they're basically
Sith
it's just not as obvious they're not you
know they just have weird [__] powers
and uh man
they're cooking dudes and feeding them
to the dogs and [__] killing people
with crossbows and [__] it's causing
people to fall in the water into the
pool and they can't break the surface
tension of the water oh yeah that's
great I forgot about that being choking
on chicken bones when they were eating
pork all kinds of yeah that was Roger
adultery yeah he choked it up in a
chicken butt mysteriously but he was
eating pork he didn't eat chicken that
for some reason that just reminded me of
that scene from The Witches of Eastwick
where like they were choking on like the
cherry pits yeah because all the witches
were like eating the cherries and
spitting the pits out and then like far
away like somebody else was like started
coughing up all the cherry pits you know
what I mean yeah I love witchcraft [__]
yeah you know what I mean she's a witch
fanatic I really love witchcraft [__]
yeah but uh but yeah so okay I guess
we'll wrap it up because we've been on
an hour oh um I was gonna remind
everybody I put up a video on my scare
Salon Channel today and if you've been
following me I've been doing like the
Boris Karloff series Thriller
um doing them like six episodes at a
time and I just put up one today that's
season two like the first six episodes
of season two and it's like an hour and
15 minutes long where I'm like talking
about them so if you're into like old
horror anthologies and stuff like that
then you might want to go over and check
that out I'm almost up to a thousand
subscribers over there which means I can
monetize it oh really okay yeah yeah I
have two other channels I have scare
salon and crime immemorial so I'm almost
to a thousand on both of those so you
can't you can't monetize the channel
until you get a thousand subscribers so
I'm trying to get like you know a few
more so I can monetize those as well so
I can put ads on them and [__] like that
um so you know I don't have that many
left to go and I can't you know I can't
um post as many as I used to on there
but it's like well now that we've now
that we're going full time with the with
the other thing I might have time to
like put more up on there we're working
from home full time now yes yeah
that's good we're gonna get [__] down at
a faster rate yeah and it's going to be
more focused on our projects instead of
other people's projects yeah because
she's still got side gigs she's got
customers that uh called her for [__]
graphic design local clubs and [__] like
that bands or whatever
yeah and uh then you got the T people
and [__] some Merchants that work
with her
um packaging and [__] but that's well
maybe a couple times a month maybe so
but yeah it's mostly going to be our our
projects now yeah we just gotta [__]
tighten the belt [__] get [__] done
yep it'll work out that's what we're
gonna do yeah
um also our next main show is Wednesday
night and we're doing more True Crime
we're gonna talk about good old John
Norman Collins otherwise known as The
Co-Ed Killer or the Ypsilanti killer uh
or the Michigan murders they also call
it that too
so that's who we're going to be talking
about on he was kind of like the pre-ted
Bundy Bundy you know what I mean Scott's
talking about Heavy Metal the movie yeah
man I own heavy metal I also own Fire
and Ice that's another one that yeah
because I think we reviewed both of
those at varying times some of my
favorite flicks heavy Metal's a [__]
trip man the loch Nar yeah and the
Blu-ray is really good because there's a
bunch of deleted stuff on it shows
before and where the black the loch Nar
came from how it evolved and [__] it's
looking pretty good yeah I don't like
Fire and Ice as much yeah but um but
it's still pretty good too it's so
pretty the problem with fire fire and
ice is that they [__] change the plot
the wolf Warrior was actually uh the
[__] father of the evil Prince right
and he was [__] killing his own son
who had gone bad that would have been
much better
yeah we thought we reviewed it so I
think we did a big long discussion on on
that like when we reviewed it a few I
think it was probably last year or
something like that we reviewed it but
yeah I think it's on Amazon Prime
actually if you have Amazon Prime I
think yeah if you guys don't know fire
nice that's [__] that's a Frank
Frazetta
drawn I think he drew did a lot of the
artwork it was kind of rotoscope it was
[__] real good animation it led to
the very first it was kind of like a
predecessor of uh the first version of
[__] um
Lord of the Rings
the animated Lord of the Rings
see I thought the animated Lord of the
Rings came out before that but I could
be wrong about that okay maybe possibly
I thought Lord Rings came out and I
don't think it was the same because that
was Ralph bakshi wasn't it
who the Lord of the Rings and The Hobbit
yeah the anime the animated ones they
were using rotoscope oh yeah yeah that's
what it was I like that rotoscoping look
it's cool looking yeah they they did a
lot that was like a big thing to do like
an animation Back In December fantasy
Adventure kind of Conan style rotoscope
fantasy [__] yeah it was big in the 70s
when I was a little kid yeah that was
right the main dragons came out the
hobby shops and the lead figurines we
were doing all that even like the Star
Trek based [__] space combat ones
where you have the little ships on the
octagonal [__] Maps we had all that
oh I remember that remember those yeah I
forgot what that was called I forgot too
but I know what you're talking about
that figures up and the guys are paying
them up
yeah Scott says yeah it was Ralph bakshi
that was 1978 or so yeah that's I
thought it was 70s because I remember
seeing that when I was real little yeah
yeah um Sebastian said are those your
Tyrell shirts Diamond gen yes
you want one we I'll send you one send
us a private uh direct message somewhere
on in our social media and uh you know I
can I can get it to you for probably
about 20 with shipping
yeah we made we scream for him like I
designed him and he screen prints yeah
make them one at a time and we just make
him one
um all right so I guess we'll wrap it up
and Tom's gonna go make some pizza yeah
and we're just gonna chill out because
we're like I said we're still kind of
worn out from you last night honestly
we're getting told for this [__]
um but no we had a good time yeah yeah
yeah yeah there you go yeah yeah yeah I
remember that right I don't know if we
ever had it but I used to see it in the
hobby shop a lot of time used to buy
some of the ships just to have them yeah
to paint them and stuff yeah that was
like super cool how do you play the game
I just had The Little Ships all right so
we will see you guys again on Wednesday
night for our main show like I said it's
about serial killer John Norman Collins
so hopefully you guys can join us for
that and we'll see you then good night